mon ordinateur il est trop vieux c'est
surchauffe de ouf
allez let's go
salut tout le monde bienvenue dans ce
live spécial français à la draft NBA
2023 puisque bon de toute façon ça sera
une draft historique pour la France du
fait de Victor when Bayama mais on s'est
déjà penché sur le cas du joueur en long
en large et en travers donc
dans cette émission on va surtout
apprendre à connaître puisque vous les
connaissez peut-être pas vous qui nous
regardez nous écouter les autres
Français qui vont participer qui ont
laissé leur nom en tout cas en tant
candidat à la draft NBA il pourrait être
jusqu'à 4 au premier tour en incluant
Victor il pourrait être aussi que deux
ou deux ou trois donc ça c'est des
choses qu'on peut pas vraiment
pronostiquer on pourra dire un peu ce
qu'on entend ce qu'on lit mais on n'a
pas on n'a pas de boule de cristal pour
pour parler de tout ça on a Manu et Luca
de la de l'équipe envergure salut les
gars
bonsoir salut salut incroyable maillot
de de majeur au-dessus de toi Manu tu
régales les fans de l'Ouest et dans son
dans sur sa c'est quoi un petit balcon
où tu as un jardin Thomas un petit
balcon je me suis mis là
salut comme Lucas sur balcon dans dans
ce qu'on ce qui s'apparente comme des
arbres et de nos jours ça fait plaisir
d'être dans les arbres et devant des
voitures c'est ça salut les gars dans le
et les filles d'ailleurs si on a dans le
dans le chat on a on attend vos
questions bien sûr pour pour parler des
Français à la draft à la draft NBA on
dira un petit mot de Victor et de ses
playoffs mais c'est pas le sujet
principal on va commencer tout de suite
en évoquant le français dont la cote
explose ces derniers temps et évidemment
ces Bilal Coulibaly vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler en tout cas si
vous suivez le basket français puisqu'il
joue dans la même équipe que que Victor
web benyama donc au Metz Luca est-ce que
tu peux pour ceux qui ne le connaissent
pas du tout nous dire d'où il vient quel
est son parcours son évolution il y a
encore un an et demi personne à part toi
Manu et quelques initiés connaissiez
l'existence et le potentiel de Bilal
Coulibaly
clairement comme tu l'as dit il y a
encore deux ans de ça personne ne le
connaissait certains l'ont vu quelques
minutes en 15 France quand il était à
Levallois il faisait 1m82 donc je pense
pas que tout le monde s'est attardé
autant qu'on s'attarde aujourd'hui mais
ouais clairement un parcours atypique
mais il était quand même assez présent
dans dans le circuit parce que notamment
il a fait le ticket 13 avec Victor
emmaniama qui sont gagnés mais un
parcours assez atypique parce qu'en U15
comme je l'ai dit il fait seulement 1m82
et il a très peu de temps de jeu avec le
15 France de Levallois il se laisse au
dos durant la saison du coup il fait
très peu de matchs et puis ensuite il y
a le covid qui arrive et là grosse
poussée de croissance grosse grosse
poussette croissance s'il arrive à un
mètre 97 pour ça
je crois deuxième année 18 donc là il
commence vraiment à performer avec par
exemple Allan Manu on commençait
vraiment à le remarquer à se dire il
sort d'où quoi parce que c'est un joueur
qu'on que moi en tout cas j'avais vu
jouer mais qui m'avait pas marqué j'ai
l'impression que c'était vraiment deux
jours différents pour le coup parce que
tu passes d'un tout petit meneur d'un
mètre 82 qui est skinny etc et là tu
vois un joueur sur le terrain vraiment
impressionnant donc ouais difficile à
reconnaître en tout cas et même
dans son année 2022 même si elle était
quand même impressionnante on n'allait
pas jusqu'à penser que il sera invité où
il serait imaginé dans potentiel le
tripic donc ouais par exemple en février
on le voyait encore au second tour ce
qui est vraiment impressionnant alors
qu'aujourd'hui on en parle comme un des
joueurs qui va peut-être potentiellement
de rester dans le top 15 donc ouais
vraiment parcours atypique et
humainement ça ça se ressent parce qu'il
a pas le
le côté encore grosse tête ou il se voit
comme un prospect NBA depuis peu en fait
donc du coup il a toute cette tout ce
côté humble etc à mettre beaucoup de
travail pour réaliser ce que j'espère
pour lui son potentiel maximal
Tom toi tu l'as vu évoluer cette saison
parce que vous avez commenté les matchs
des Metz quel pour ce qu'on pas trop
regardé ces matchs là comment évoluer
son rôle au fur et à mesure de la saison
en fait quel rôle il avait sur le
terrain maintenant c'est une des
évolutions les plus incroyables qu'on
ait pu voir dans basket français je
pense
de par le côté physique physiologique
dont tu parlais Lucas mais aussi parce
que
ton volume de jeu a totalement explosé
en quelques mois il est passé quand même
d'un mec qui était dans l'équipe
d'espoir en début d'année il devait être
dans le groupe pro et jouer avec le
groupe pro un petit peu quelques minutes
voilà prendre le temps de sa guérir
mais en fait Vincent coller vu quelque
chose en lui et lui a répondu présent
très rapidement dans la saison lorsqu'il
y a eu des blessures et que la saison
mettre c'était très compliqué eu des
blessures des évictions des bagarres des
machins des trucs mais Bilal gratuite
grappiller ses minutes petit à petit
jusqu'au point ou Vincent Collet lui a
fait confiance d'abord sur les petites
en Dieu et rapidement dans le sac majeur
finalement pour arriver à être l'un des
joueurs majeurs pendant ce playoffs LNB
avec un rôle on va pas dire leader parce
que ça reste un très jeune joueur et
c'est un très jeune dans le groupe même
si le effectif est très jeune au global
voilà ça un caractère de jeunot qui qui
va s'affirmer avec le temps j'ai envie
de dire que son jeu représente pas
forcément sa personnalité qu'on peut
qu'on puisse imaginer alors qu'en fait
dès que tu commences un petit peu à lui
parler c'est un peu un mec et une grande
gueule pas une grande gueule mais en
tout cas
qui a beaucoup de choses à raconter
c'est pas intimide dès que tu commences
à avoir des relations avec lui donc
on parle du potentiel plus tard mais ça
me fait dire que bientôt
ton jeu est-ce qu'il pourrait faire sur
un terrain se rapprochera de ce qu'il
est avec ses très proches voilà avec un
mec de confiance et c'est ça qu'on peut
mettre sur avance la confiance qu'il a
en lui quoi je pense qu'il avait même
pas conscience du talent qu'il avait en
début de saison et entre Vincent Collet
la relation qu'il a eu Victor très
importante histoire le pouce énormément
alors qu'ils sont pas depuis toujours
enfin de la même année et tout il est il
fait figure un peu de grand frais en
tout cas dans dans le travail dans la
muscu dans dans le sérieux dans le
professionnalisme donc ouais il est il a
bluffé tout le monde franchement tout le
monde que ce soit les scouts les gens au
club et et tout le monde quoi tout
simplement et Vincent Collet Tom qui lui
laisse même même dans les playoffs tu
disais de son rôle qui a évolué presque
leader en tout cas qui lui laisse des
répétitions avec le ballon qui lui donne
des responsabilités y compris avec le
ballon quoi pendant une quand il sortait
encore du banc etc on était plus sur un
joueur de cut ou de transition ce genre
de choses là il porte le ballon parfois
il va jouer les piquets roll il va faire
il va se lâcher
le match 4 contre
tout ce que les gens rêvent de lui à une
vitesse inimaginable en fait il a toute
la période du bon masketteur la
polyvalence le physique le Jump je
rajoute ça dans le physique
chose qui qui peut l'amener en tout cas
sa forme et la confiance peuvent
l'amener dans les bons pourcentages être
fiable à terme tout ça il est en lui
maintenant il faut lui faire comprendre
que tu es capable de le faire et mine de
rien avec le temps qui peut te faire les
erreurs le temps la confiance du coach
être comme tu dis la répétition et ouais
le match de las veulent il a tout fait
pour sur le terrain j'ai dû un contrat
de dire expert
des trucs de fin de possession
j'imagine que tout le monde était sur le
cul même je même si vous vous l'avez
peut-être vu assez tôt que il avait
peut-être allé avoir un potentiel et
tout mais ouais franchement ils boivent
tout le monde
son parcours le moment où tout le monde
se dit ah il y a peut-être un truc c'est
le match avec entre brownies à Nanterre
ou c'est le meilleur score du match mais
c'est un peu passé à l'air si je trouve
et là c'est ressorti ça il y a deux
trois semaines en fait il avait déjà
tout ça en lui maintenant il fallait
juste bah qu'il le fasse régulièrement
et avec confiance est-ce qu'il a fait
Manu qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on va
acheter parce que comme le disait Lucas
aujourd'hui on parle quand même de une
promesse l'autre hippique de de ces
choses là quoi on parle de joueurs qui
l'année prochaine fera plus de plus de 1
million cinq j'ai plus la grille des
salaires du firstick de faire se remplit
mais c'est ça veut dire que ton que la
franchise qui te draft investit beaucoup
que ce soit
en argent pur ou même en moyen qu'elle
va mettre à développer ça veut dire que
que c'est important pourquoi on va
investir là dessus on va rentrer
vraiment dans les qualités de Bilal
Coulibaly avec toi magnifique
moi j'achète c'est la la polyvalence
offensive c'est un mec qui est capable
de jouer sur les postes arrière 1 et 2
assez facilement même voir trois
syllabes croissance continue un petit
peu et si le shoot vient parce que
franchement c'est offensivement c'est
assez impressionnant de le voir Savoir
Tout Faire déjà en fait moi je l'ai je
l'ai surtout vu en espoir parce que le
quand je suis allé à Levallois il jouait
pas trop trop encore avec les pros mais
c'est un c'est un gars qui joue qui est
capable de jouer meneur qui va remonter
la balle qui qui va savoir se cacher et
faire des cuts il a essayé de la fête
très très bien on est en pro ou on le
voit débarquer nulle part et faire des
coups de bac assez impressionnant
franchement ça c'est vraiment ça qui les
flash offensifs sont sont fous mais il
est aussi très très bon défensivement
[Musique]
il a pas fini sa croissance j'ai
l'impression
déjà moi ce que j'ai aperçu sur entre
l'été 2022 et le début de saison je sais
pas si le local avait remarqué aussi mon
sens il a grandi rien que sur ces quatre
mois là il avait grandi et moi je pense
qu'il peut gagner encore quelques
centimètres aussi et ce que
défensivement je pense au moins un deux
peut-être trois selon le ce qui pense
qu'il a physiquement latéral pour pas
pour pas se retrouver en patinage
artistique face au garde NBA qui sont
qui sont vélos qui sont bas en terme de
centre de gravité qui vont donc allier
un peu vélocité puissance moi je pense
pas parce que honnêtement le le corps
est assez bien fait en fait que t'as pas
de dérange trop haut tu as pas un petit
un petit bus ou quoi c'est c'est
vraiment
parfum proportionnelle pour proportionné
et donc au début je pense au moins 1 2
et à terme selon la capacité physique
qu'il a d'ajouter ou pas du muscle
peut-être du 3 voire du 4 mais là je
suis vraiment moins moins sûr quoi
peut-être en fin de carrière tu vois
mais au moins ça au moins du 1 2 est
possiblement trois je pense
Luca pour pour avoir du temps de jeu en
année 1 est-ce que finalement manu a
effleuré ça mais est-ce que finalement
quand même son son grand atout c'est pas
la défense c'est clairement moi en tout
cas si je me mets à la place des
franchis c'est ça que j'achète en
premier lieu c'est un gars que tu vas
prendre d'abord dans un profil trendy et
puis ensuite on a les deux en année 3 tu
vas le mettre en jelly pour qu'il puisse
avoir la balle en main qui continue à se
développer dans un rôle de plus leader
en fossible on va dire parce qu'il y a
des vrais flashs à la passe il y a des
vrais vrais flash offensifs dans la
création ballan-main il trouve toujours
dans un pur un contrat même en global il
trouve toujours un moyen de faire la
différence avec son nom
son adversaire mais dans une première
année je le vois pas du tout dans un mec
qui je donne la balle en tout cas il y a
encore trop de d'une expérience je
trouve même on le voit beaucoup de
ballons ouais c'est ça
hyper quand même beaucoup de ballon
quand tu vois le temps de qui passe dans
ma main donc dans une première année je
dois beaucoup plus dans un rôle de
trendy parce que comme tu l'as dit pour
moi c'est vraiment en tout cas ce que
j'achète chez lui en premier pour pour
rentrer dans le détail de la défense
c'est c'est de la mobilité latérale il y
a de l'intelligent aussi l'intelligence
of ball on sait que système NBA sont de
plus en plus évolués défensivement si
t'es pas à la page année 1 2 tu te fais
griller tu joues pas tu te fais mettre
sur le banc
surtout ce qu'on trouve qu'on
sous-estime c'est son envergure il a
2018 envergure
2018 alors que il défend sur des postes
en deux donc franchement
c'est vraiment un plus value une
plus-value impressionnante il peut
défendre sur un deux et pour l'instant
il peut pas encore défendre selon moi
sur les postes 3 mais comme l'a dit Manu
ça viendra jamais notre carrière parce
que là il a encore de d'enfant on
l'oublie parce qu'il tamponne ils font
dans les playoffs mais c'était encore un
enfant physiquement donc je pense que
aller dans 4-5 ans on peut l'imaginer en
défendre sur des postes 3 mais pour
l'instant on reste sur du post en deux
plus la mission défensive comme
comme on le voit aujourd'hui qu'on est
playoffs et il a pas peur du contact
comme tu disais ils font ce il y va
alors qu'il est fin quoi
[Musique]
des joueurs frêle un peu évités aller
sur du flotteur et tout lui plus plus
sur la photo offensive que sur le
flotteur Bilal Coulibaly une question du
chat et ce sera pour toi Tom passe la
grosse question est-ce qui est-ce qu'il
est pas est-ce qu'il est pas un peu en
train d'être surcoté on se pose souvent
la question avec les gens qui montent
tard comme ça dans la draft on se dit
ouais c'est un peu des hype de
construites par ce qu'il y a tellement
de jeux d'influence aussi qu'est-ce que
tu en penses
est-ce que ça cote est exagérée j'ai
envie de te dire que il y a que l'avenir
qui pourrait le dire parce que dont je
suis sûr c'est que personne se trompe
sur le fait que ce gala vraiment un
obsède extraordinaire il a il a vraiment
un truc différent des autres fin de
saison dans tout le monde connaît ses
victoires donc tous les scouts qui
venaient c'était pour le voir lui il y
avait dû aussi du Armel Traoré mais
c'est vraiment pour le voir lui jouer
parce qu'il y a un truc qu'on a pas dit
là c'est que c'est un garçon et un
joueur très très intelligent et ça dans
la NBA moderne un athlète
un gars qui est très long qui monte des
flashs offensifs sur tous les aspects du
jeu qu'il met des tirent ça franchement
il a réussi à être vraiment à droit et
presque fiable cette saison avec une
grosse progression attendue c'est des
mecs qui va le faire tout simplement
c'est des mecs qui veulent cher je
rajoute à ça que il joue pas dans
l'obert thème League et je pense ainsi
j'aime bien rappeler quand même ça parce
que on entend les Américains parler tout
le temps bla bla bla bla bla là c'est
les ça joue sérieusement des mecs qui
sont payés cher en face c'est le mecs
qui veulent te bouffer c'est le mecs qui
veulent pas descendre qui vise plus pour
être en Europe etc etc si ce mec-là
arrive à faire le match 4 qui fait
contre las veulent une équipe de Ruy non
ça cote elle est pas usurpée parce que
parce qu'il produit déjà des choses que
tu peux imaginer plus tard donc
j'ai pas on verra dans le temps bien sûr
ça se trouve ça sera un boss et on sera
tous là comme des cons mais il a fait
trop de bonnes choses ces dernières
semaines
avec une progression fulgurante pour ne
pas avoir les yeux qui brillent c'est
simple façon la draft non c'est à un
moment donné bon bah qui te fait kiffer
le plus possible à l'instant T et ben
Bilal il fait kiffer énormément de monde
en ce moment
je pense qu'elle est pas exagérée elle
est juste amplifiée à cause de Victor en
fait
parce qu'il jouera dans une autre équipe
il serait un peu moins vu et un peu
moins connu et je pense que c'est il
aurait eu le parcours qu'à l'époque on
imaginait c'est une draft 2024
alors ça c'est important que tu dis ça
si vous voulez pour parler vite fait
lui son entourage ses agents et tout ils
sont posés la caution ou pas assez
longtemps sur on y va on y va pas c'est
une bonne question c'est est-ce que
c'est trop tôt c'est peut-être trop tôt
clairement le problème c'est qu'ils ont
eu des certitudes de tellement de
d'équipes de franchise sur les
interviews les machins les entretiens
avec les tout le monde est dithyrambique
quoi toutes les équipes tous les scouts
sont dithyrambiques donc ça aurait été
trop bête de pas en profiter
on l'annonce parfois top 7
voilà
j'étais en mieux de
s'en révéler le nom de franchise ou quoi
que ce soit des choses qu'on a pas le
droit de dire Tom mais pour toi de ce
que tu de ce qui te revient ça c'est
rumeurs de Bilal loterie pour toi c'est
du concret pour toi ça va partir l'autre
ah mais moi si papa loterie c'est un
désert
je crois qu'il sera loterie maintenant
on sait jamais le mine de rien il y a
aussi ce truc que lui il est pas allé
faire les workouts il a pas fait le
drive combat il a pas fait tout ça donc
on reste sur ce fameux flou à la dentée
il voulait pas venir faire les workout
donc tu payes tu payes sur plan avec
avec lui
voilà tu payes tout à fait Manu
tu payes tu payes sur plan avec avec
Bilal et quand tu payes sur plante et
pas parfois tu es sur un coup de coeur
mais c'est un coup de cœur que tu as pas
vraiment vu t'as pas visité la porte
donc
tu vas moi je vous le vêtements va faire
la grappe ensemble on peut le dire
encore une fois et je ferai mieux qu'on
puisse le refaire
six 14 il est pas parti je serais
dégoûté ok tu serais dégoûté pour lui en
premier lieu ça l'empêchera pas d'avoir
une carrière si il est 15e mais on va
dire ça
il y a Rémi sur sur Twitter j'avais
demandé de poser des questions avant
Rémi qui qui demande au-delà des
capacités physiques techniques est-ce
qu'on peut parler du mental parce que
c'est vrai que finalement pour les
joueurs qu'on a évoqué un peu en
buzz parce que il y en a qui reste des
belles années de carrière mais mais si
on parle de ses coups de Bouya même si
on parle de
alors Kylian ice c'est peut-être plus
une question de rôle
comment il situe au niveau au niveau
mental Luca tu disais il a pas encore
l'habitude de de ça de cette notoriété
soudaine est-ce que est-ce qu'il est
carré en fait dans sa tête et est-ce
qu'il est en même temps assez affirmé
pour pouvoir s'imposer parce que par
exemple un Francky lukinat c'est
peut-être aussi ce qui scapule lui
manquait à certains moments de sa
carrière
franchement Bilal il coche toutes les
cases et quand tu fais les Intel tu te
dis presque tout le monde tout le monde
le nous manque ils exagèrent mais des
échos que qu'on a c'est que c'est
vraiment il a les pieds sur terre
c'est un bon gars qui reste ouvert
malgré toute la hype etc et tu parlais
de Franck tilkina pour moi quand tu as
le parcours de Bilal que tu arrives
quand même à t'imposer dans un effectif
avec Victor avec des joueurs qui autour
c'est pas c'est pas des peintres c'est
des bons joueurs tu arrives à t'imposer
à trouver ton rôle dans cet effectif là
alors que tu es seulement en 2004 c'est
que ça prouve que tu es capable de
t'imposer même dans la grande ligue tu
arrives dans un effectif tu as un an
d'espoir dans les jambes
et encore un endroit dans les jambes
avec seulement des flashs parce que même
l'année dernière en 2020 c'était pas lui
qui avait la balle c'était assez mignon
c'était Maxime miomi
ericumba c'était le troisième c'est le
troisième homme des espoirs alors que il
a le side
stratosphérique comparé aux coéquipier
mais de réussir à s'imposer en
étant pas un leader en U21 et il arrive
dans ce vestiaire est réussi à trouver
une place comme ça au milieu de l'année
c'est que pour moi il peut vraiment
s'imposer
je reviens juste sur la défense Lucas
c'est une question qui me vient
maintenant
à quel point avoir Victor derrière soi a
pu gommer les défauts qui existent
encore il y en a toujours dans la dans
la défense de Bilal Coulibaly
est-ce qu'il est vraiment capable de
vous parler de défendre des 1 et des
deux je remets la même question mais
est-ce qu'il est vraiment capable demain
d'aller gêner des mêmes des mecs de ses
communes tu vois mais des bons gars de
ce communitenba
pour d'aller les gêner d'aller faire
chier sur les postes un et deux quoi de
de passer les écrans avec les épaules
etc est-ce que sans avoir la sécurité de
se dire bah peut-être que je peux
laisser ces 50 cm de plus parce que
derrière moi il y a un type qui a 2 m 45
d'envergure
est-ce que je trouve bien c'est que même
si à Victor hi derrière lui en défense
on se calmant cette année j'ai vu aucun
je pense que Thomas a vu plus de
dommages de Black que moi mais j'ai vu
aucun moment où tu vois qu'il se dit bah
je peux pas ça en dessous l'écran parce
que quoi qu'il arrive je vais switcher
avec Victor
donc j'ai pas besoin de faire les
efforts et pour moi est-ce que il peut
gêner des mecs de seconde unit très
clairement latéralité pour en tout cas
même des grosses lâcheurs je pense qu'il
aura latéralité pour pour les tenir et
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure son
envergure elle change quand même
pas mal de choses et comme le dit Tonio
pour revenir à la question
d'avant il a clairement la rigueur que
c'est que nous Mouillard on savait qu'il
n'avait pas alors que là c'est vraiment
totalement différent ces deux joueurs
vraiment
diamétralement opposé je te rejoins
complètement et
on avait deux formes d'athlètes
totalement différentes je te rejoins
franchement c'est ils sont incomparables
il y a un 3 et 4 et il y a un véritable
extérieur voilà pour moi c'est un
extérieur Bilal là vous parlez de
défendre sur les postes 1
je crois que c'est un mec de défi
voilà donc c'est un gars si tu lui dis
là ce soir tu défends sur ce mur de jeu
parce que tu vas bon profil il ira mais
dans un premier temps je suis pas sûr
que l'envoyer sur tous les meilleurs de
la semaine tous les meilleurs meneurs
des blancs et NBA ce soit une bonne
chose voilà il a d'autres qualités à
faire valoir c'est un vrai bon défenseur
il a intelligent il y a des longs bras
on l'a dit tout à l'heure je crois que
dans un premier temps que c'est un
arrière-relie et que son jeu se fait
contre les arrières alliés et pas encore
à ça de manière de jeu qui peuvent qui
seront très très rapide par contre dans
3-4 ans on en discutera de ça l'année
prochaine le voir en mission tous les
soirs contre un honneur de jeu seconde
unique je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
meilleure idée du monde c'est pas lui
faire un cadeau peut-être bah non c'est
clair et si on peut éviter de flinguer
nos joueurs français c'est pas mal
manuel est pour toi cette question du
chat qu'est-ce que les jumeaux Thomson
en majuscule ont de plus que Bilal
Coulibaly
puisqu'ils sont vus plus haut uniquement
alors c'est une question légitime les
jumeaux c'est surtout des fric
athlétiques
mais je pense qu'on imagine même pas ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire
peut-être que les gens sont un peu plus
les fins les entre guillemets les
sous-estimes parce que c'était de l'over
time élite mais les scouts qui les ont
vu en vrai ils sont tous ils sont tous à
bas sur 10 parce qu'ils peuvent voir
quoi c'est juste c'est juste monstrueux
qui c'est du Jalène green plus plus
ça qu'ils ont en plus après en terme de
terme un peu galvaudé mais en termes de
cuit basket je pense que Bilal est un
bien meilleur
et le lance ce qui fait la diff il a
laissé de là et après ce qui est un peu
identique ce serait peut-être le tir ou
mais ce qui est difficile de de projeter
les les jumeaux Thomson vu l'adversité
qu'ils ont la ligne à trois points
qu'ils ont
c'est compliqué de là-dessus c'est
compliqué mais
cela pour répondre à ce que à la
question le s'il y a une chose à retenir
c'est vraiment le
l'athlétisme et donc le
en déduisent l'escoutes aussi le
potentiel maximum parce que à ce niveau
là de la draft on pense on pense plus au
plafond que au scénario média quand on
parle d'un joueur
Manu je te poursuit c'est intéressant
d'abord cette problématique du tir
c'est pas des pourcentages
extraordinaires qu'on a pour Bilal cette
année au tir qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
tu peux me dire qu'est-ce que tu penses
de sa gestuelle est-ce qu'elle est en
amélioration et
et ce qu'on l'a est-ce qu'on l'achète à
assez court terme parce que pour fouler
un parquet NBA et avoir des minutes au
bout d'un moment il faut il faut rentrer
ses tirs
moi s'il y a que ça tient qu'à moi
j'aime beaucoup la forme enfin je trouve
qu'il y a pas trop de fioritures elle
est assez clean là dessus après il y a
une
amélioration à se voit aussi surtout sur
le la différence de niveau espoir
Betclic élite ou en espoir il était un
peu haute que ce qu'il faisait au début
en Betclic c'est qu'il était cantonné un
peu au corner
il arrivait plus à se créer pour lui du
tir mais ça jamais été son truc numéro 1
mais je convoie la forme qu'on voit les
les stades sur le sur les lancer moi j'y
crois ce sera jamais un shooter élite
élite comme on l'entend mais
s'il est à 37 38 % moi je pense qu'il
peut y arriver à ça
un truc
non je trouve que là on a vraiment été
complet sur sur Bilal niveau projection
etc on a vraiment bien
décrit profil donc du coup j'ai pas j'ai
pas j'ai rien à ajouter que je pourrais
dire tu vois par rapport à la forme et
ça réussite
au contraire je trouve que il me bluffe
parce qu'il est capable de mettre dedans
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il est il
est capable et ce qui sera capable
d'être très fiable à appliquer 40% NBA
on verra mais déjà 40% c'est 40%, c'est
normal
vous dites ça moi ce que je puisse avoir
plus plus dans les coups quand je
réfléchis je le vois et tout il me fait
penser à une combattu
le jour intelligent physique avec long
segment post-3 qui est capable de scorer
mais qui aime faire des passes surtout
qui aiment dans le collectif qui est
très bon défenseur quand je vois comment
Nico a été à progressé sur son tirage
parlons pas depuis qu'il est occupé et
sur un nuage et globalement ça car c'est
un gars fiable du tir à 3 points moi je
pense que Bilal il peut avoir ça en lui
c'est à dire que là aujourd'hui il a
encore un tiers d'enfant il a les pieds
dans le cinéma
de toute façon il a 18 ans mais
donnez-lui trois quatre ans de muscu
donnez-lui trois quatre ans de 1000
tiers par jour
je douille pas ça me paraît être il est
capable il a ça en lui d'être un jour un
shooter à 45 évidemment que c'est énorme
mais fiable déjà fiable avec trois
quatre tirs par match et ça c'est ça
c'est énorme mais c'est aussi pour ça tu
dis j'achète quoi j'achète aussi le
potentiel aussi en attaque d'être je
pense qu'il sera jamais un gars qui va
porter la balle sur cette action etc par
contre quand tu es le troisième joueur
qui est capable de faire la bonne passe
dans dans un sac à la nicobatum et ben
tu trouves ta place assez rapidement NBA
si tu fais des bons choix donc
en tout cas je vais juste revenir sur le
truc du tir c'est que tu parlais des
pourcentages sur les pourcentages en
saison il tire pas beaucoup mais mine de
rien il y a des pourcentages assez haut
qui ont surpris tout le monde et qui
peuvent être répétés peut-être pas la
prochaine mais d'ici trois ans quand il
aura plus de 20 ans le mec et là j'ai
passé le bac donc voilà
[Musique]
et dans cette 19e année puisque c'est
l'âge minimum pour pour être candidat à
la draft on le rappelle Thomas toi te
pour finir là dessus tu dis l'Autriche
serait déçue pour lui tu aimerais le
voir chez qui dans cette loterie
elle est compliqué il y a des trucs
évident j'ai envie de te dire le premier
qui me vient c'est mAbs en 10
voilà j'ai une équipe qui a
leurs alliés c'est nous quatre les mecs
donc s'il pouvait
aller
réfléchir à avoir des mecs à potentiel
qui peuvent leur apporter dans quelques
années leur remplaçant de Doriane
finesse pourquoi pas mais tu vois c'est
pas exactement le même profil et tout
non c'est l'idée c'est l'idée donc ouais
franchement mal dans 10 avec des restes
à côté avec une belle histoire à
raconter avec un français sur place on
verra si Franck mais voilà et puis et
puis les terres de comme sport là-bas
donc voilà je j'aimerais bien je dirais
comme ça je serai très content si Ryan
pouvait suivre dans la foulée le bas
là je veux que mon Manu il enlève le
t-shirt il fasse tourner le serviettes
alors je te donnerai mon t-shirt
tu est-ce que tu souhaiterais rester
avec nous pour parler de Ryan Thomas
d'ailleurs qui est adorable la seule
chose que je peux dire sur Ryan c'est
qu'il y a une super famille voilà c'est
c'est je vais je vous quitterai
là-dessus sur un repère mais voilà en
tout cas on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine jeudi prochain pour vivre ce
premier tour ensemble en espérant qu'on
ait quatre Français au premier tour j'y
crois moyen mais on sait jamais tu
disais tout à l'heure
les derniers échos c'est qu'il y en a
que trois
Bilal et Victor en haut dans le top 15
et ensuite Ryan et ensuite Sidi Sissoko
nous chez envergure on a plutôt 6 dit
dans le top 30 mais c'est plus en terme
de valeur de ce qu'on pense nous des
joueurs si dit Bilal et Victor dans le
top 30 et Ryan à la limite quoi autour
de la tranche et navire du coup
et Nadir on l'a racheté par ouais mais
c'est une question apparemment il y a
des choses qui sont sorties sur ces
workouts apparemment il y a vraiment
fourni au-delà de ce qu'on a vu sur les
réseaux et tout ça apparemment il y a
vraiment son idée mecs au point que
je parle de lui quoi on verra si il est
drafté
a fourni des mecs comme il fournit
depuis deux ans en mec qui dit
ça va limiter si ça son plus gros point
faible en fait
à fond
on va dire il m'a il m'a bluffé pas par
son tour
exceptionnel non son parcours est fou et
tout vous le savez mais le match qu'on a
pu commenter au Portel contre les Metz
défensivement il fait un mauvais match
il fait un pas un bon match d'attaque
cul par terre pression tout terrain cœur
énorme je vais ah mais attends là si tu
peux faire des trucs comme ça tu changes
de dimension parce que tout le monde le
voit il y a des mecs je les mettent qui
défendent pas beaucoup malheureusement
et tout le monde le ressent et c'est ce
qui leur limite limitera l'accès à la
NBA plus tard mais la vérifier à montrer
dans des matchs de très bon niveau
contre des professionnels qui étaient
capables de défendre il est petit mais
il a des cannes donc avoir et puis et
puis il fournit les mecs de son âge donc
au bout d'un moment
gros moteur gros compétiteur n'a dirifi
pour pour faire pour pour terminer la
parenthèse sur lui c'est le cinquième il
est pas vu drafter pour l'instant mais
le second tour il y a toujours des noms
qui tombent on a l'impression d'en avoir
jamais entendu parler quand on a pas
bien suivi et même quand on a suivi
d'ailleurs donc
voilà le Luka est-ce que tu peux tu peux
rappeler qu'il est rapide aussi
bah franchement on a dit dans de cette
cuvée là pour moi c'est la plus belle
des histoires en tout cas c'est un gars
qui c'est un coup du destin une famille
qui a rien à voir avec le basket il
déménage en face d'une salle de sport un
gymnase de basket il passe ses journées
dedans à regarder à commencer à jouer il
commence tard alors que souvent ceux qui
commencent tard c'est les grandes 2 m 17
alors que là il fait 1m84 il commence
tard il est pas pris au centre de
formation de Strasbourg par rapport aux
résultats scolaires etc devant des mecs
en mode Beaufort friche etc il arrive au
Portel franchement je sais pas j'allais
sur Boulogne à Boulogne-sur-Mer mais
c'est dur donc ça c'est dur je sais pas
comment tu allais tourner la chose mais
bravo
il commence à opporter et il nous
impressionne simplement une impressionne
ça son année avant de jouer avec les
pros moi ça a été ma première année où
j'ai vraiment suivi de championnat
espoir et
franchement il nous a vendu durée et
pour moi
au vu du profit de l'histoire de tout le
storytelling derrière
[Musique]
il y a peut-être des chances faudra
rester en fin de seconde tour et ça ça
sera incroyable qui qui je pense déjà
c'est sûr qu'il aura un spot à la
semelle en ligue en tout cas il y a
forcément une équipe qui va miser sur
lui au vu des workouts etc et ouais
franchement on a dire c'est vraiment une
belle histoire et j'espère que ça se
finira ça se finira au second tour et
que il aura sa chance dans un roaster
mais après si moi si je suis une franche
des NBA malgré l'histoire etc
je miserais pas forcément sur lui au vu
de son physique comme l'a dit Manu et
surtout un joueur de cette taille pour
moi quand tu lui donnes la balle tu
attends un minimum de comment je
pourrais dire ça
j'ai envie que quand j'ai un menant dans
cette taille je vais passer à balle et
je suis sûr qu'il me fasse aucune paire
de balle quoi alors que là il a plus le
profil un peu fou fou à tenter des pas
etc donc ouais à voir s'il arrive à à
changer ça et on sura ça très proche le
José Alvarado de la Côte d'Opale dit
Julien dans le chat
c'est beau franchement ça c'est un bel
hommage
[Rires]
après après je me dis toujours que le
basket elle a NBA réserve toujours des
histoires il y a toujours de nouvelles
histoires à raconter
j'ai du mal à croire qu'un jour il
puisse être un oubliée et jouer en NBA
mais il a tellement réussi à chaque fois
à péter le plafond qu'on lui mettait
quand je dis 11 c'est pas moi mais c'est
pas de niveau c'est les coachs qui n'ont
vu passer c'est mais qui croyaient pas
en lui et tout
tu sais quand tu es comme pour
en train de grimper les échelons comme
ça il y a rien qui peut t'arrêter il est
dans une formule olympique et il sera
avec la frenchelen team là encore une
fois pour se montrer un petit peu plus
sur Los Angeles contre une féroce équipe
de l'Arménie il faut que l'arménien je
trouve que ça remet il y a deux matchs à
Los Angeles donc
[Rires]
[Musique]
une draft deuxième tour une semi une
bête de saison avec Paris Basket et puis
après on verra voilà
merci les gars merci à toi d'être passé
Tom on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
chez la First Steam pour vivre la draft
ensemble draft qu'on espère
extraordinaire et qui sera de toute
façon unique pour le basket français à
plus tard vous êtes vous arrivez en
forme je vous en forme je veux que mon
Manu il arrive chaud patate
sera peut-être ailleurs pour la draft on
verra d'accord
bonne soirée bon courage à tous bonne
soirée à vous
à qui à qui à qui on va faire la suite
est-ce qu'on parlerait pas de Ryan
Rupert
rien de Rupert
fils de frère de ok est-ce que tu peux
rappeler qui il est Lucas son parcours
avant qu'on se penche sur tout
comme tu l'as dit fils de Thierry Rupert
frère de Ruppert
il commence le basket à Chalon en basket
il y a pire comme comme premier club il
part ensuite du côté
de Coulaines et ensuite il rejoint le
mans15 France pour ensuite après passer
par le 6 quand date etc et il arrive à
l'INSEP ou là on a tous on a tous connu
en tout cas beaucoup beaucoup plus vu
que moi mais voilà c'est un peu près son
parcours rien de très
atypique en tout cas mais ouais parcours
classique pour le France non et ensuite
maintenant du coup la NBA avec les news
breakers
cette année qu'est-ce qu'il a fait Manu
là-bas en NBA
beaucoup sur la fin de saison mais oui
bah il a été malheureusement il était
blessé ouais mais c'est fracturé le
poignet droit je crois
c'est son poignet shooter donc si je
crois que c'est le droit
éloigné des terrains pendant
trois deux trois mois
et il est revenu les revenus un peu
avant les play-offs NBA
du coup
ça blessure la clairement freiné dans sa
progression on l'a fait une très bonne
précision avec les breakers ou voilà il
avait des vrais missions défensives et
c'est là qu'il est le plus impressionné
il a aussi montré des belles choses au
tir qu'on n'avait pas trop l'habitude
enfin il avait il mettait dedans en fait
au tiers ce qu'on avait pas trop
l'habitude de voir à l'INSEP ou avec
l'équipe de France et puis la blessure
là un peu un peu cassée dans son élan et
en playoff on l'a juste surtout vu sur
des missions défensives
le shoot était plus rien dedans ouais il
était beaucoup moins dedans au tir je
crois qu'ils finissent la saison à 28% à
3 points ce qui est ce qui est
catastrophique mais ça malheureusement
le tien a toujours été son point faible
c'est ça jamais été son
à l'INSEP il portait la balle en équipe
de France il jouait un peu deux un peu
trop
c'est c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
après en fait c'est comme c'est un
bosseur qui a quand même des qualités
défensives pour moi qui sont élites il
est une envergure je sais pas combien
elle est peut-être à peu près comme
Bilal est de 10 de 20 entre eux 18 entre
2 18
en vrai franchement c'est assez
impressionnant il a encore tes bras
immenses il fait encore plus on a
l'impression qu'il est encore plus
d'envergure que que Bilal moi j'ai
l'impression que je le vois
c'est assez impressionnant l'impression
que c'est
il a des bras incroyables c'est la plus
grosse différence taille envergure de la
draft
devant Jordan Walker comme ça qu'on le
voit en vrai tu as l'impression que
c'est doit toucher je suis quoi
franchement
c'est assez immense de 2021 2m21 dans la
gueule
ça lui permet de d'avoir des missions
défensives comme tu le dis là c'est
latéral pour la description du jeu de ce
qu'il a fait cette année je vous invite
ce qui nous écoutent c'est à à se rendre
sur notre portrait qu'on a sorti la
semaine dernière pour trait de Ryan
Rupert son profil draft en 20 minutes
pour compléter ce qu'on va dire ce soir
mais mais clairement la blessure a pas
du tout aidé et pourtant il est toujours
vu comme un comme un premier tour
pourquoi en fait Luca comment on le
projette
quand on se met dans la peau du GM qui
qui va activer le bouton on espère pour
Ryan deuxième partie du premier tour
comme mon projet de ce pic quoi on lui
fait faire quoi l'année prochaine on lui
fait faire quoi dans trois quatre ans
comme l'a dit Manu vraiment
défensivement il est clairement élite il
est clairement élite
un peu un peu à la manière de Bilal mais
vraiment en step au dessus parce que ça
fait déjà deux trois ans que c'est
vraiment son
ça plus value qu'il apporte à l'équipe
son envergure qui est impressionnant et
sélectionne de jeu of Ball qui est
vraiment qu'apporte beaucoup à son
équipe
après pour sa projection moi j'ai
offensivement en tout cas
si j'étais un j'aime ça me poserait
problème parce que son tir il est il a
mis dedans récemment mais avec sa
blessure du poignet etc on peut pas
vraiment l'évaluer
récemment mais forcément il s'est plus
compliqué en tout cas même sur le
spot-up s'il est pas grand ouvert il va
prendre du temps à déclencher son tir
etc donc sa projection elle est un peu
elle peut en tout cas être rapide étant
donné que ça peut être un profil
seulement défensif et même pas un Trien
dit puisque offensivement il arrive pas
il a des difficultés sur le tir et ouais
donc sa projection il y a potentiel qui
n'arrive pas à développer son tir et que
du coup ça lui posant un problème pour
la suite en tout cas mais défensivement
c'est vraiment ça que qui va pousser le
GMA appuie sur le bouton comme dites
ouais c'est ça
est-ce que c'était une question de cinos
sur Twitter est-ce qu'il a un potentiel
plus que seulement bon friendy s'il est
déjà tué une 10 ce serait ce serait pas
mal vu le potentiel en défense qu'il a
en fait quand on dit lui Andy il faut
être élite dans un des deux et très
correct sur l'autre
manutois toi est-ce que tu draves devant
ou derrière Sidi c'est une question de
Paul dans le chat
pas si c'est moi qui suis au manège le
drame derrière
mais je suis quelle raison
pourquoi je dropshidi ou pourquoi je
voudrais
pourquoi pourquoi tu tu t'es un peu
tiède sur le potentiel de Ryan sans dire
qui était froid mais ouais parce que
offensivement c'est il part de trop loin
il y a pas de tir
il peut pas aller au cercle il peut pas
finir au cercle
du coup ça le pénalise beaucoup trop
c'est ça veut dire coffensivement il est
quasiment négatif en fait pour son
équipe
si ça le truc faut s'il a un truc à
améliorer d'emblée sur ces deux
premières années pour moi c'est du catch
and shout
en fait fautif faut qu'il arrive à parce
que je pense qu'il sera très vite pas
défendu en l'image d'un Bensimon
français extrême mais voilà
c'est cuit qui sanctionne un minima ce
qui s'il est ouvert vraiment au début
c'est ça
c'est un peu le fil conducteur des trois
Français sur lesquels on fait le focus
ce soir alors Bilal a quelque chose en
plus et peut-être un petit peu plus de
garantie mais on va dire aussi plus ou
moins la même chose sur CDIS Soko
ensuite le shoot et la clé
juste du catch and shout ne demande pas
parce que là on a fait beaucoup de
joueurs aussi quand même mais oui mais
en fait les joueurs qui réussissent en
NBA ils arrivent à mettre dedans quoi
c'est assez simple mais quand tu
regardes les cinq les cinq de fin de
match sur la finale NBA et même sur les
playoffs il y a pas beaucoup de gars qui
shootent à moins de 33% sur le terrain
quoi ou alors c'est des c'est des bars
des maillots enfin destreux donc je
trouve que pour Ryan en tout cas
la question du tir bah ça se changerait
carrière quoi s'il arrive pas à
développer son tir il y a moyen qu'il
soit de retour en Europe après son
contrat Rocky alors que si un Sidi a
plus du mal à défendre à développer son
tir
même avec son tir actuel Sidi
il restera dans la vie malgré qu'ils se
sentir à évolue pas franchement
pour Ryan c'est vraiment primordial de
développer ce tir là plus que les autres
profils je trouve et malheureusement
pour lui cette blessure au poignet elle
est donc pas arrivée au moment opportun
parce que comme tu disais Manu ça
commençait un peu à cliquer en tout cas
on voyait des petits progrès on voyait
qu'il avait bien bossé dessus etc et
effectivement bah déjà
ce que je disais dans le podcast sur lui
mais
pour ceux qui jouent au basket
imaginez-vous juste vous tordez le doigt
sur votre main qui shoute ça vous
dérègle tout quoi ça vous dérègle tout
même quand vous revenez etc donc ce
péter le poignet évidemment que ça met
du temps pour revenir j'ai une autre
théorie sur son tir mais elle est bien à
moi ah vas-y on aime ça c'est je pense
en fait il a des trop longs bras
la gestuelle et tout elle est un peu il
y a des fioritures parce que du coup il
n'a pas encore mais il n'a pas son tir
en fait c'est pas réglé et on le voyant
je trouve que il y a ça il y a il y a
des théories
morphologiques qui mettent en relation
les joueurs la longueur de bras des
individus et leur adresse c'est pas il y
a aussi la largeur des mains blablabli
mais c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
assez documenté si vous regardez ce
qu'on est tout petit bras c'est rare qui
shootent
est-ce que vous avez des trucs à ajouter
sur Ryan Rupert
moi je pense que
comme il est tellement bon défensivement
c'est qu'importe le contexte je pense
qu'il arrivera à s'en sortir
OK
du moment qui te coûte pas de points en
fait tu peux le mettre sur le terrain
juste quand les matchs deviendront
importants il le sera pas ça c'est sûr
et il a parce qu'au bout d'un moment
offensivement il sera ciblé et s'il
n'arrive pas à répondre ça va est-ce
qu'il a dans le dans la boutique des
trucs qui peuvent compenser en fait on
pense à des joueurs qui savaient pas
trop shooter en début de carrière mais
qu'on réussit à gratter des temps de jeu
en étant soit avec un énorme moteur tu
vois hyperactif que ce soit rebond
défensif offensif offensivement aller
chercher des des poudbacs aller faire
vivre des possessions aller chercher des
cuts être des poseurs d'écran même en
étant même en ayant pas forcément la
carrure d'un poseur d'écran mais en
étant intelligent etc est-ce qu'il a ça
en magasin aujourd'hui
pour moi non
compliqué pour toi
que je fais confiance à Manu là-dessus
il a vu beaucoup plus que moi mais au
prix au premier abord je te dirai non de
ce que j'ai vu
en tout cas j'ai vu aucun clip de lui
alors qu'aujourd'hui j'en ai regardé
quand même pas mal où je me suis dit il
y a vraiment quelque chose of Ball qui
peut apporter à la manière d'un client
de ma voix et qu'on a vu à la NGT toute
cette activité of goal avec les foodback
etc je vois pas ça en tout cas chez lui
s'il confirme c'est que c'est bon
une question du chat c'est ce qui est un
problème de verticalité
j'ai pas pensé mais ce que vous en
pensez
c'est pas les plus grands athlètes les
repères
est en bon état
comme il a pas cette capacité à terminer
au cercle en fait à se diriger au Cercle
du coup c'est on le voit pas il tient
pas forcément beaucoup le contact il va
pas te lâcher des tomates dans le dans
la circulation
donc de verticalité ça dépend ce que
Richie entend
parce que
ouais c'est une icône
toi tu dis c'est plus de la gestion du
contact une fois en l'air donc ça peut
être de l'appréhension enfin on est tous
différents là-dessus appréhension du
contact proprioception gainage etc
bon pour Ryan Rupert donc qui est malgré
tout vu dans le top 20 on avait
peut-être l'air un peu négatif mais
Jonathan givoni la placer dans le top 20
de sa moque draft qui est sorti
aujourd'hui sur espiènes on passe au
troisième larron troisième larron si
d'ici Soco qui jouait donc en jillig
night cette année
Luca pareil est-ce que tu peux nous le
présenter avec aussi les mensurations
parce que je les ai pas sous les yeux si
tu les as de dire ça alors
pareil à la rue paire et à la wembi
famille de basketteur
papa qui a joué dans la sélection
nationale du Sénégal le grand frère
Boukhari qui est en N1 à Kaysersberg et
la grande sœur qui est pareil jouer un
très bon niveau
en basket féminin et au niveau des
mensurations il est à 2 mètres 3 pour 92
kg au dernier nouvelle
je l'ai à 2m8 mois au final 8
j'ai 28 et 23 donc voilà on choisit je
pense que c'est plus
et du coup il commence le basket à
Draveil dans le 91 qui est ensuite il
rejoint Centre Essonne en U15 France et
au cours de la saison il rejoint un
basconnia en Espagne où il va être formé
avant de partir à
dans United il est même en dessous de
mettre 3 il a il est plus petit crâne
Rupert il a c'est les mesures du combat
c'est 650 sans chaussures donc ça fait
1m97
donc avec chaussures 2 mètres de mes
tubes ça ah non c'est l'envergure qui a
2008 excusez-moi
ouais il a des longs bras aussi et du
coup donc tu disais bascogna et ensuite
le choix de rejoindre la iggnate donc
qu'est-ce que tu as vu lui cette année
tu bouges
moi j'ai vu un joueur polyvalent que ce
soit en attaque ou en défense c'est
vraiment moi ça qui me qui me fait
l'adorer en fait ce joueur c'est que
c'est cette polyvalence et aussi sur le
fil de sa jeune carrière c'est qu'il a
connu plusieurs choses déjà il est en
Espagne il jouait beaucoup meneur
porteur de balles sur les postes
arrières et Angélique il jouait beaucoup
plus sur les postes 3-4 du coup il a
déjà deux rôles différents en tête qui
peut appréhender en équipe de France U18
l'été dernier c'était il était un peu
entre ces deux eaux là aussi des fois
porteur des fois à l'intérieur
donc ça c'est
pro en fait déjà plus voilà il a le la
mentalité espagnole la mentalité
américaine tu es un peu ce double ce
double je dirais cursus qui qui va
l'aider et en fait il a eu pour
l'instant il est pour moi il est moyen
un peu près partout mais il a un
potentiel vraiment quasiment illimité
partout aussi quoi
c'est c'est franchement en termes de de
jeux de transition de passe de vision
c'est assez
fort très très fort je pense qu'il va
qui va surprendre plus d'une personne en
fait et que
et sur ces grandes qualités Lucas sur
sur ce que les ce que les GM peuvent
acheter pour compléter ce que disait
Manu
la polyvalence clairement Manu l'a dit
ce qui est un GM va acheter chez lui je
pense c'est la polyvalence
défensivement comme un Bilal comme un
Rupert il va pas te coûter de panier
même si offensivement
à part des écrans et un peu de jeux pour
les autres en première année je pense
pas qu'il apportera grand-chose
offensivement mais il y a un potentiel
vraiment facilement là un peu à la Boris
bio chez les Spurs de vraiment
faciliteur pour les autres j'ai la page
qu'à dire playmaker mais vraiment
faciliteur il y a une vraie vision de
jeu il comprend le jeu ce qui est ce qui
est pas du tout donné pour un jour cette
position et cette taille donc ouais en
tout cas c'est ce qu'un GMH très sur moi
ouais et défensivement Manu pour rentrer
un peu dans le détail on parle de de
d'un mec qui peut défendre sur combien
de poste
esquive est-ce qu'il est aussi efficace
of ball tu vois dans les aides présents
quelle qualité précise il a qu'on
peu bien aimé dans un dans un dans un
jeu NBA dans un jeu en général
sur les postes qui peut défendre je
pense
qu'au début donc sur les années 1 à 3 je
pense qu'il sera beaucoup plus sur du
poste de poste 3 peut-être 4 selon les
les Small Ball enfin les les
physionomies des rencontres et des ce
que va faire l'adversaire
et moi ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
bosser son activité surtout il est
toujours actif vraiment intéressant sur
les interceptions et coup vraiment bien
les lignes de passe un peu il a quelque
chose aussi au contre c'est pas
forcément ce qui saute en premier mais
en terme de tu n'as pas peur d'aller au
contact
c'est c'est surtout ça et moi c'est
vraiment les choses c'est deux choses là
qui me qui me font cocher des cases pour
lui et son entrée en NBA
on demande quel rôle quel rôle il aura
Luca toi tu le vois comment alors
j'imagine que c'est en année un c'est
une nouvelle fois cinos qui pose la
question sur sur Twitter
en année moi je le vois comme un trindy
même si le tir à trois points c'est
plutôt compliqué pour l'instant mais ça
peut devenir correct d'ici quelques mois
parce qu'il y a des flashs quand même au
final tiens à trois points et ensuite
avec les mois qui vont passer plus
d'aisance dans le jeu être plus à l'aise
etc prendre ses marques
pourquoi pas un rôle de facilité
forward qui va vraiment
distribuer
la balle mais moi je le vois plus comme
un post-4 en tout cas pas je sais qu'il
y a une discussion de savoir si on
projette en tant que poste 2 comme il
était à bascogna ou plus le profit qu'il
a maintenant avec la jelly Night et moi
en tout cas je le vois beaucoup plus
dans un profil à Ladji good night où il
pose des écrans sur des systèmes il peut
jouer au post-op et lâcher des caviars à
côté donc ouais je le vois vraiment dans
un profil comme ça dans son année
il y a un vrai potentiel de hic c'est un
très bon passeur c'est un très bon
passeur qui a qu'à pas eu beaucoup
l'occasion de jouer avec la balle mais
même il s'est joué un pick and roll quoi
sur la fente possession et donc quand tu
sais jouer en pick and roll tu sais
jouer un chartreux
donc donc effectivement s'il arrive à
poser à poser des écrans c'est c'est pas
mal du tout Manu j'ai une question très
précise alors là va falloir être bon
c'est un auditeur américain ou un
lecteur peut-être probablement sur
Twitter qui qui parle de la
su-agressivité de Sidi Sissoko puisque
c'est vrai que parfois on défense ça se
livre un peu trop il a fait beaucoup de
fautes cette saison etc
est-ce que pour il demande est-ce que
pour vous ça vient de de d'un manque de
contrôle du corps
ou c'est plus de encore de la
l'immaturité c'est à dire de la
discipline défensive un manque de
discipline défensive
à un peu trop aller chercher le
défenseur un peu trop cherché la balle
après j'ai lu la question et j'avais pas
j'y réfléchis depuis tout à l'heure et
je en fait j'arrive pas trop à
comprendre ce qu'il veut dire mais
comme toi tu l'ex pour moi c'est ça pour
moi c'est ça c'est pour comment ça se
fait qu'il fasse autant de fautes ou que
parfois il se livre autant et que du
coup il soit il soit un petit peu
dépassés par par les événements mais on
lui demandera de préciser en réponse à
son tweet
mais en tout cas effectivement c'est un
joueur qui peut qui peut être projeté
sur plusieurs positions comme vous
l'avez dit tous les deux donc si d'ici
Soco que nous on a entre 20 et 30 sur
notre board nous Manu à titre personnel
on a tous les deux 15e je crois
donc c'est plus un joueur en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai vu cet après-midi je
crois en regardant moi c'est un joueur
auquel je crois
je vais je vais je vais plaider pour
pour Sidi Soko un petit peu mais je
pense que il y a déjà des basses solides
au tir la seule chose qui est toujours
inquiétante et que j'aime regarder c'est
le pourcentage au lancer franc qui est
pas qui est pas extraordinaire
mais à part ça
je pense que en fait les joueurs qui ont
un gros coffre comme ça parce que les
joueurs un peu fins à la alors Bilal il
doit encore ajouter du muscle et ça se
voit qu'il va le faire mais à la repère
ou
d'autres qu'on a vu débarquer en NBA
c'est une ils se font un petit peu
rouler dessus quoi alors que Sidi en
fait du fait de son épaisseur il peut
jouer plus grand que sa position
aujourd'hui pour moi plus que
l'envergure tu peux jouer plus haut que
ta position si tu es épais quoi tu peux
jouer plus haut que ta taille si tu es
épais c'est pour ça que Fred van vint a
une carrière NBA c'est parce que le mec
c'est un cube quoi c'est un cul personne
le bouge et c'est vrai pour plein
d'autres joueurs c'est pour ça que dream
on green a une carrière extraordinaire
alors oui il a des longs bras il a un
cerveau énorme mais il a aussi enfin il
ne cache thoracique développée de
mammouth quoi donc c'est pas que c'est
pas que du muscle c'est aussi de la
psychologie et moi j'adore la
morphologie de Sidi je vois un centre de
gravité bas je vois un gars qui peut qui
peut switcher très très facilement et un
gars qui impacte quand il y a quand il y
a son coéquipier qui se prend un
backdoor bah déjà lui il l'a vu parce
que sur les aides défensives il est
quand même très très il a une activité
particulière ça se voit qu'il a des
réflexes déjà de mec qui joue en pro
depuis un moment et et quand il y va le
gars qui prend Sidi Sissoko si Sidi mon
droit c'est plus difficile de finir que
s'il va prendre un tout fin voilà c'est
c'est leur côté mini Zion peut-être pas
mais
c'est quelque chose de d'assez
impressionnant pour moi le côté épais de
Sidi Soko et de positif en fait j'allais
dire pour sa projection NBA c'est pour
ça que je l'ai aussi yo au-delà du fait
que
le tir
ma nu peut-être la bémol sur le tir
c'est peut-être encore la mécanique
parce que sur les résultats ça vient
petit à petit mais le bémol c'est
peut-être la mécanique
ouais c'est vrai après
j'ai pas le tir en tête là j'ai pas la
gestion en tête mais
je trouve pas que au moins sur du catch
and shout il peut y aller assez
rapidement tu vois il est pas gêné dans
sa gestion dans sa prise de balle il
fait pas des gestes qui résistent
moi je pense que ça va venir le tir on
répète tous les ans mais c'est l'une des
caractéristiques les plus faciles à
travailler et à s'améliorer donc
j'imagine que qu'il aura du personnel à
ses côtés de grande qualité
donc j'ai pas trop d'inquiétudes je
pense qu'il ce sera très rapidement un
rôle player plus plus en fait pour son
équipe pour avoir du temps de jeu il
faut tout truc et je pense que c'est
pour ça qu'il est projeté pas espiènes
enfin en partie pour ça
en dessous de d'un Ryan Rupert c'est
parce que pour gratter du temps de jeu
il faut toujours un truc pour lequel on
te met sur le terrain si tu es un peu
bon partout ça sert à rien en vrai ça
sert à rien
si c'était si tu es capable de faire un
peu de transition mais que tu es capable
de
faire une passe de défendre un peu
correctement c'est bien
mais il faut que tu aies un truc que tu
apportes de fou fou quoi tous les
joueurs qui ont du temps de jeu dans les
matchs importants ils sont une
spécialité ça peut être des spécialités
à la con ça peut être de l'activité de
l'activité offensive
couplée à une énorme intelligence ça
peut ça peut être des rebonds ça peut
être voilà des choses comme ça mais il
faut que si 10 soit soit énorme en
transition soit énorme en défense pour
pour gratter du temps de jeu rapidement
et je pense que c'est pour ça aussi
qu'il est pas forcément projeté mais bon
comme tout comme les trois dont on a
parlé ce soir est très jeune donc
évidemment c'est difficile de décider
enfin de décider
deux autres
et je veux pas énormément y jouer
on explique le contexte quand même Manu
tu as scooter Anderson
il faut quand même lui donner le ballon
même si tout le monde sait qu'il sera
qui sera raft et top 3 il fallait quand
même qui bouffe et quand il était pas là
on avait du Léonard Miller
à qui on essayait de donner des
répétitions avec le ballon parce qu'à la
base Léonard Miller c'est un peu comme
Billy il a grandi très tard il s'est
retrouvé avec un corps de 2 m 09 alors
qu'avant il en faisait 90 et du coup il
s'est
ils sont dit bah on peut peut-être en
faire quelque chose quoi alors ils ont
essayé de effectivement c'est un
playmaker correct meilleur mais tout ça
pour dire que c'est disoko c'est pour ça
qu'il avait pas le même rôle comme Luca
disait qu'à basconnière quoi donc donc
c'est un contexte un peu particulier
effectivement
toi tu toi tu l'envoies ton premier tour
du coup Manu
tramissidi tu crois son potentiel
d'intégrer un roster
encore une fois si c'est moi mallette
oui et oui c'est ce que je te demande je
demande pas si bah de toute façon les
gens manettes on leur parle pas pas
encore
mais voilà je suis pas toujours dans les
25 30 là je sais pas qui a
ouais faut regarder un peu les équipes
qui ont peut-être plusieurs choix de
draft mais mais c'est pas sûr s'il
faudrait qu'il ait des répétitions
ils peuvent aussi tenter un gars en se
disant lui on le fait jouer angélique un
an quoi
et je pense il aurait peut-être plus de
d'opportunités s'il est dans s'il
atterrit dans une équipe qui a déjà des
standards qui a déjà un plan en tête
qu'il arrive pas dans une équipe pour
reconstruction tu vois où on s'est mis
reconstruction qui vise rien en fait lui
enfin moi je pense qu'ils sont potentiel
sera beaucoup plus
développé et ce sera beaucoup plus il
sera presque Plug and Play tu vois dans
une équipe
qui entre 6 et 10 tu as fans playing tu
vois oui tu veux dire que c'est
un rôle Player qui est prêt à apporter
du coup si tu le mets dans une équipe un
peu à laquelle des trois il sera dans un
rôle qui lui correspond forcément pas
forcément et du coup si tu l'évalues sur
un rôle qui lui correspond pas ou
forcément il sera moins intéressant
alors que là demain il atterrit dans une
vraie dans une vraie équipe comme dit
Manu va chercher à gagner des matchs
franchement tu as un bon coach tu
l'utilises bien c'est c'est de la
rambarde
et du coup c'est vrai que ça va avec le
côté cérébral du joueur c'est le genre
de joueur qui plus l'équipe est
performant autour de lui ça c'est c'est
une règle générale mais c'est encore
plus vrai pour lui lui il va se mettre
aussi au niveau de l'équipe
faire faire briller les autres c'est
plus sa qualité enfin rendre le meilleur
encore meilleur c'est plus sa qualité
que de rendre le médiocre moyen
il est projeté autour de quoi demande tu
Marceau dans le chat
deuxième tour aujourd'hui la mobdrof de
Jonathan givoni j'ai pas regardé
récemment the athletic à sortie son son
drive
qui est fait tout seul
aujourd'hui où hier je l'ai pas je l'ai
pas encore lu mais généralement c'est ce
qui ressort c'est du fin de premier
début de seconde
en tout cas même s'il est début de
seconde ça peut être des débuts de
second avec des contrats intéressants
pas forcément des débuts de seconde avec
des contrats
deux ans sous-payés et tu te casses quoi
donc enfin sous payer
ça peut un peu un contraste peut être un
contrat à la théobale et donc un vrai
contrat alors qui était draft
donc voilà est-ce que est-ce que vous
avez des choses à ajouter
Manu Luka sur sur un des Français on n'a
pas parlé de Victor
on en a beaucoup parlé il est bon lui
est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui vous ont
surpris pendant ces playoffs quoi
c'est qu'il est humain il a fait un
mauvais match quand on Monaco ça m'a
rassuré un peu
il est capable de
faire des matchs à côté quoi et même
défensivement il est à côté mais il est
quand même énorme quoi c'est juste
offensivement il a pas mis dedans il est
vraiment ici il est ciblé aussi on voit
très bien que le gars escouter là à fond
et que ils ont très vite compris que
c'était un peu la pire angulaire du jeu
et du coup il est je sais plus qui c'est
qui branle je crois je sais plus je sais
plus les noms
[Musique]
c'est tellement bien défendu je pense
que là les équipes NBA apprennent déjà
des notes
c'est pas les mêmes tous les Européens
le disent c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'attaquer en NBA que
en Europe y compris embêtent qui est
quand même une ligue avec des ouais
voilà des gros débats qui viennent te
mettre des coups quoi
qui viennent te coller qui viennent et
puis tu peux être pris à deux sur un
tout petit sur un espace qui est pas
gênant pour la défense tu peux être pris
à deux assez facilement quoi donc et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait Victor
dans son interview à la force immédia
moi je sais que là c'est
ça fait un an que j'ai pas pris enfin
depuis le début de l'année j'ai pas pris
un seul tir en un contre un quasiment et
la raison
il est souvent comme deux un mec qui est
en train d'arriver dans l'aide et du
coup il faut il faut se dépêcher alors
bon une aide sur weba Niama c'est quand
même moins efficace qu'une aide sur
quelqu'un d'autre parce que quand tu
quand tu shootes
de mettre 62 haut je sais pas combien
c'est son lâchés de balle qu'on est-ce
qu'il a été mesuré en hauteur mais c'est
quelque chose d'assez spectaculaire
voilà donc Victor web benyama humain et
les autres qu'on espère au premier tour
on sera chez la First Steam et
probablement dans d'autres médias on
vous tient au courant on n'a pas encore
calé tout ça mais envergure sera présent
allover the place pour pour vous donner
parce que bon on n'a pas scouté que les
Français on a on a fait notre boulot
toute l'année on a des fiches en plus
finir du film qui a été regardé voilà
Manu il a mal aux yeux il a il a trop
regardé de overtime Elite avec les
commentaires et du coup
et du coup c'est maintenant que ça paye
donc voilà allez voir nos nos autres
vidéos enfin en vidéo podcast sur sur
les profils draft pour pour s'il y a des
gars qui vous intéressent pour les
franchises donc vous êtes donc vous êtes
supporters ou juste des noms dont vous
avez entendu parler
effectivement
Darking il y aura probablement un canapé
à BeIn Sport qui sera occupé par
quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien et et qui
aura sous les yeux des fiches envergure
donc voilà ça fait toujours plaisir de
vous voir nombreux franchement vous avez
été quasiment une centaine tout le long
là donc vous nous avez régalé on vous
retrouve on vous retrouve chez First
Steam et ailleurs et en attendant aller
sur le site aller sur la chaîne Youtube
donnez-nous des pouces des pouces en
l'air pour pour qu'on soit bien noté et
pour que le travail de toute l'équipe et
je m'inclus pas dedans parce que tout ce
qui est écrit et tout ce qui est préparé
pour les podcast c'est pas moi donc
vraiment toute l'équipe mérite et je
vais pas tous les citer maintenant mais
mais mérite des vos pouces en l'air et
pour encore combien de profils draft en
podcast au moins
7 8 j'ai calculé tout à l'heure combien
dans mon cœur dans cette huit si on en a
tourné six aujourd'hui déjà donc tu peux
on a oublié Mady Traoré
il est candidat oui c'est la parole
Mady Traoré attention
53 minutes de jeu cette saison donc à
son à surveiller peut-être le plus gros
style de la draft on sait pas encore
mais
où ça
je savais pas mais c'est Costa non
je sais pas du tout j'ai oublié le
je vais dire ça mais ouais j'ai regardé
des clips au cas où
par contre
[Rires]
ok bah après voilà
New Mexico state
de Julien je crois les conférences de
l'Ouest donc il est pas là moi j'ai pas
vu je vais pas parler de ce que je parle
Enzo
ah oui on avait un message au début
quelqu'un qui trouvait ça surprenant le
Blake Griffin français comme dirait
quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien Lucas
surprenant
après parce que
je connais pas la règle en Europe t'as
pas de limite au nombre de fois où tu
peux te présenter à draft donc tu es
dans l'âge si je crois que c'est une
fois pour tout le monde
[Musique]
Enzo qui tente sa chance cette année
tout le meilleur mais c'est vrai que
c'est un peu surprenant il a pas trop de
hype en tout cas à notre connaissance ou
très atlantique mais on n'a pas toutes
les infos et peut-être lui on a d'autres
je sais pas
en tout cas merci de nous avoir suivi et
gros bisous tout le monde on vous
retrouve pour la draft on a hâte pour
cette draft historique pour le basket
français ciao ciao ciao